[Music]
[Applause]
brian clark joins us on loan from the
mothership ryan we've been talking about
name image and likeness uh where are we
headed with this in college football
i mean it's just a legal way of cheating
this is not
you know all of a sudden you know
everybody's like oh it's used as a legal
recruiting tool it's always been a legal
recruiting tool this is not this is not
a new thing you know now they can just
do it publicly and now the rich will
continue to get richers because the
teams that were paying the people before
now they could pay them you know over
the table on top of the table and get
these kids to come to school and i think
this is what happens when mark emirate
and the ncaa wants to wash their hands
of actual issues or wants to wash their
hands
of actually helping these young players
out and getting to a point where name
imaging like this wasn't the wild wild
west where there were some rules and
some restrictions
and some regulations and because they
refused to do that that's why we found
ours find ourselves here
what's your best recruiting story that
you heard that somebody got
or offered
um
you know
like i don't really listen
uh to be honest i've heard a lot of
recruiting stories from dudes in the
locker rooms and
different things like that but i don't
really have a best recruit story you
know those are for other people to tell
you know i drove a pink s10 until i
graduated and my first year in the
league i caught a ride
with a teammate and so i don't have a
recruiter store where people offer me
any money because i wasn't no good and
so that's about all i know
see you wouldn't have cashed in on name
image and likeness ryan
well well once i was in school i i
certainly would have because i was a
good player by that point yeah
but but coming into lsu you were you
were not going to be cashing in
oh no not at all not at all coming in
coming into lsu they might have made me
pay them come to the school
uh with the weight with the way i was
being recruited you know i've heard of
duffel bags of 50 000 dollars being left
uh you know i i know tons of kids
who drove better cars than me while i
was still in the league you know but
those those are stories uh you close
your ears to where you never tell
uh he's ryan clark in the mothership uh
explain to me how deandre hopkins got to
this point being suspended for six games
um
you know how it works uh you know you go
in you take your performance enhancement
test
uh the test comes in and you know
they bring you the the bad news they
bring you the bad information not
necessarily sure
you know what deandre uh indigested or
or what he
or what he took but it's definitely you
know right now it's a bad look for him
it's a bad look
for the nfl when when one of your best
players
you know
someone of his caliber you can now put
into question his career now here's what
we know
julian edelman um also tested positive
for performance enhancement drugs
and when his career was over you know
there were people in my business that
said you know he should be a hall of
famer and so
if that's any indication
of what happens going forward i think
deandre hopkins legacy is fine but to me
this definitely tarnishes what you have
done on the field
and it also puts in question
all of your accomplishments now deandre
hawkins was the first wrong pick he's
been good for a decade in this league
and so i believe people
understand what a talent he is but i
know for any player especially someone
who believes they were doing things the
right way this is the last thing you
want on your resume but everybody says
it's an accident ryan
like like how does how does somebody of
deandre hopkins stature
or even edelman that you get popped like
if you're smart enough then you know how
to sidestep this stuff
unless you've been doing it all along
well i think i think the the biggest
thing is the and this is what i i do
believe that people believe they're
smarter than they are and you also begin
to trust people that you don't
uh that that don't know right or trust
people that you shouldn't and so you're
expecting that if you take a certain
thing then they'll be able
to mask it or they'll be able to get you
through the test and you also listen to
people when they tell you this is
undetectable but the bottom line is man
you do the right things you follow the
guidelines and you'll be okay you know
in 13 years i was always the best player
no was i always the guy who's the
biggest strongest fastest no but i was
always me you know and i could you know
go to sleep at night understanding it
uh when do you think the cardinals got
an idea that they were going to be or
could possibly be without uh
deandre hopkins and therefore making the
trade with hollywood yeah the cardinals
knew that before the weekend obviously
okay oh i can't tell you exactly but
they knew before the weekend then i
tweeted yesterday that now it makes
sense you know uh i'm sitting back uh
i'm watching the draft you know what i'm
saying it's the you know 57th nfl draft
class i gotta be a little crown royal
and i'm watching the draft and i said oh
look at this they draft you know they
got hollywood bro hollywood brown hasn't
necessarily been
the guy that
the razor expected him to be the last
year he came along a little bit you know
he's had touchdowns and you give up a
first and third form it was it was kind
of uh it was kind of crazy to me you
know i was looking at it and didn't
quite understand it and then this news
comes out and it makes total sense and
now and after week seven you have your
two guys that can really play and you
hope you're in a position to make a run
what are you doing with crown royal
besides drinking it
well you know what i'm toasting this is
this it was the 57th uh nfl draft uh
chrono royal sent out super bowl
packages to
you know all of the different nfl
legends and we got an opportunity to
bring this class in you know these
players are embarking on something that
a lot of nfl legends which i am not a
lot of nfl legends um have done and
things that they've taken and so it's
not only about playing football but they
get an opportunity in their communities
and i think that you know crown royal
who is an official sponsor wanted to
make sure that these guys got a deluxe
package these nfl legends so they can
toast the people that are coming on the
journey right behind them
good to talk to you ryan as always
thanks for joining us
vanpacher you are the man you are a
legend i just want to tell you when
people call me to do extra shows on days
i don't have work this is one of the few
shows i'm actually excited about
thank you ryan i'll toast you with some
crown royal
have a great one that's ryan clark
mothership draft analyst